So to understand query world a bit more, you going to
add another filter to the query in your query playground
method. So now here we get all the conferences, sorted
by name, filter on the city is London, e filter on
topics is medical innovations, filter on month is six. But
now I'm going to add one more filter, I want to filter
on max attendees greater than ten. Now I'm going to run
this query on localhost. I'm going to try it out in the
APIs Explorer. Oops. Got an error. How did that happen?
But look, it's got some good information in here. If
you get an error, read it carefully. Remember, you can
copy and paste it into an editor that renders HTML
to make it easier to read. So it's now your
turn to add an inequality filter. Add a filter for
max attendees greater than ten, and then go ahead and
try the query on localhost. And test it out using
the APIs Explorer. I'm guessing that you're
going to get an error. But what caused
the error? Is it because the first sort order is a name, but the
inequality filter is on max attendees? Or is it because the composite index does
not exist? Or is it because you have too many inequality filters in one query?